- Alright so is everybody
that we're expecting here?
- [Teacher] Yes.
- Awesome, cool.
Well, it's so nice to see you all.
My name is Lizzie.
I may have met a couple of you
who were possibly at our LAB
Experience program last year,
I'm really excited to have you all here
with us again for LAB Backstage.
LAB Backstage program was kind of born out
of our LAB Experience program,
in the hopes of connecting
scientists to students
in middle and high school
to talk about the work that they do,
and also to talk about
sort of who they are,
and how they got into science,
and conveying the human
perspective of all of this.
And so it's kind of informal in that way.
We invite you all to ask questions,
either in the chat
or through raising your hand and speaking.
And yeah, we're really
excited to have you all here
to learn with us.
So our speaker for this
LAB Backstage is Irem,
and she will be telling you guys all
about the awesome research that she does.
So without anything further,
I'll pass it along to Irem.
- [Irem] Hello, thank you
Lizzie for the introduction.
My name is Irem.
I am hoping today to
show you our laboratory
and a little bit talk about the research
that we are doing in our lab.
But before I kind of go
into the science part,
I kind of first want to introduce myself.
And as I said, my name is Irem,
and I am from Turkey.
I grew up in Istanbul.
Sorry, my phone is making an echo.
I'm just gonna leave the meeting.
Okay, it's little.
It was distracting me otherwise.
Okay.
So yeah, I'm from Turkey.
I grew up in Istanbul,
and I did all my undergrad
studies in Istanbul, in Turkey.
And I become interested in science,
I guess in middle school,
but mostly in high school.
I always enjoy my biology classes.
And in middle school
like my science teacher,
he was great.
We did a small project in lab together.
Actually, the only thing I did
was kind of holding a beaker.
I really did nothing,
but it was still so much fun.
And in high school,
But I mean, I guess in middle
school with that experience,
I kind of already knew
that I liked biology.
I like learning about the environment.
But I kind of didn't know
how to become a scientist
because there is no
scientist in my family.
My parents they didn't go to grad school.
So I didn't have an idea that's like,
"Oh, when I grow up,
I wanna be scientist."
I wasn't thinking about that.
But in high school,
at the end of high school in
Turkey, we take this exam.
And based on your exam score,
you choose a department in university,
and also the which
university that you wanna go.
And when I was in high school,
I was searching for different majors.
And then one thing I see
was like molecular biology.
Again, I had no idea about
molecular biology is,
and then I just google it,
and read blogs of students
studied molecular biology,
and tried to learn a little bit about it.
And then I visited the universities
and ask the students in person
and also the teachers in
the universities in person.
That's basically how I
kind of decided that,
"Okay, that's really what I wanna do."
Even then, I actually really didn't know
about how to become a scientist.
As I said because I really
didn't have an example.
But then during my college,
I actually had the
chance to do internship.
I start first working in
laboratories in my own university,
but also in summer then,
I had the chance to go to United Kingdom.
And I had the chance
to do a summer research
at University of Cambridge.
And there are actually
very cool summer programs
and scholarship opportunities
for a college students.
That's how I visited England.
And during my summer research internship,
I actually decided,
"Okay, I want to do my PhD,
and I want to become scientist,
and I want to do research basically."
And yeah, and now I'm here
at Rockefeller University.
I am a third year grad student.
And this is actually,
as I said,
I grew up in Istanbul.
So I came United States for grad school.
I haven't been here before,
and I still feel like I'm a tourist.
I really love New York city.
I love walking around the city.
Like this current neighborhoods.
I am a food person.
I enjoy trying different foods.
And I kind of have this fun poll question
that I want to ask you,
so that we kind of get to
know each other better.
And I want to ask you,
what is your favorite New York's foods?
And you guys can choose the option.
- [Lizzie] So for those of
you who are in a classroom,
you can put your answers in the chat.
If one of you wants to just like add them,
and we can read them out too.
- [Participant 1] So tell me
one thing, and I'll put them.
- [Participant 2] Maybe, pizza.
- [Participant 1] Pizza?
- [Participant 2] Yeah.
- Also feel free to like,
if you have any
recommendation of any place,
feel free to write the chat.
As I said,
I still feel like I'm
a tourist in New York,
so I would love to go
there and try. (giggles)
(faintly speaking)
- [Teacher] What do you like?
- I forgot to add soup, sorry.
- [Teacher] So what do you like?
So what do you like?
Pizza?
- Rebecca, what do you like?
(faintly speaking)
What?
Eddie, what do you like?
- [Student] Sausage.
- [Teacher] What do you like, Alanna?
What do you like?
(faintly speaking)
- What?
What's your favorite food?
- [Student] I like everything.
- [Teacher] You like everything?
(faintly speaking)
Okay.
- [Participant 5] Alanna
likes sausage roll.
- [Participant 1] What?
(faintly speaking)
- [Student] She likes acai bowls.
- [Teacher] Okay.
(faintly speaking)
- [Teacher] I know.
(faintly speaking).
- Yeah, it is difficult to chose.
I like every food too. (giggles)
- [Teacher] What else you like?
Pasta?
(indistinct chatter)
- [Lizzie] So while everybody
is adding in their answers,
I shared the poll responses.
- [Irem] Yeah, there
are many pizza people.
I love pizza.
Soup, I love soup.
I'm trying to learn to cook more at home.
And I'm trying different type of soups.
It's so cool.
I never tried,
is it called a Acai bowl?
- [Lizzie] Acai.
- [Irem] Acai bowl.
My accent can be a little weird. (laughs)
Yeah, and also if I don't
pronounce your name correctly,
please correct me.
Okay, that's cool.
I guess, the food is something
that connects all of us.
I love food so much.
Yeah, I guess I can start
showing you our laboratory.
And I will first start
with a very short lab tour.
Then I will basically
talk about our research,
and then I will show you some tools
that we are using in our lab,
which is actually one of
the most commonly used tool
in our lab is microscope.
And we will look some of the samples
under microscope together today.
Okay, I will try to connect
with my phone again,
or maybe actually, I can
show my bench with my laptop.
Okay, so this is my bench space.
No, actually the phone will be better,
sorry for this.
Let me quickly join the
meeting with my phone.
Okay.
Cool.
Great.
Yeah, this is much better.
So this is my bench.
And although each labs have
different research topics,
the labs all actually look quite similar.
Each person has their own bench.
Here, this is where we do our experiments.
And during we do experiments,
we wear a protective
equipment such as gloves.
Actually, once while
I'm wearing my gloves,
I wanna quickly ask you,
why do you think scientist
made this protective equipments?
(indistinct chatter)
- [Teacher] What do you say guys?
To protect themselves?
- [Student] Yeah.
- [Student] Both.
- [Teacher] You say both?
(indistinct chatter)
(laughing)
(faintly speaking)
- Okay, so...
Okay, yes.
Most people said it is both,
and it is true.
Oh, I'm switching my laptop again.
Okay.
So we wear protective equipment
to protect both ourselves
and also for our
experiment for our samples.
You are right.
And the reason why we want
to protect ourselves is
as you can imagine,
when we are doing experiments,
we are using some dangerous chemical
that can be harmful for us.
So we need to protect
ourselves from those chemicals.
And we need to also protect our samples
because in our experiment,
because let's say I want to
make two different solution.
I don't want anything outside
to go inside that solution.
So we need to keep everything clean.
And one thing we use to kind
of sterilize everything is ethanol.
It's not surprising at all
to hear that because also,
oh, okay.
Okay, maybe I should...
Yeah, so we use ethanol to
basically sterilize everything.
This is basically like a hand sanitizer
but the alcohol part.
So I will clean my hands with this.
And one of the most basic equipment
that we use in our lab is the pipette.
So the pipette we use to
transfer different liquid,
to transfer liquid.
Here...
By the way, you can ask me any questions
through chat or if you'll raise your hand,
we can unmute you.
So with the pipette,
we can set the volume
that we want to transfer.
Here for example, this is 1000 microliter.
And I can, here, change the
volume that I want to transfer.
And this is something we use every day.
And we also have this kind of small tubes.
We add our samples in it.
So this is basically how our labs,
our bench space looks like.
And they have other
different equipments based
on the experiments we want to do
such as, this a gel tank.
This is we use to run agarose gel.
And agarose gel is basically a gel
we use to separate DNA.
So this is how my bench spaces look like.
And today, I will not be wearing lab coat,
because we will not be really working
with any dangerous chemicals,
but I will still keep my gloves
because I will be touching my bench.
And my laboratory,
we are here working on
something called stem cells.
And before kind of introducing stem cells,
I want to first a little
bit talk about what cell is.
And one of my favorite thing to do
is actually watching movies.
So I kind of like using films
to describe what cells are,
so bear with me.
So, you know in films,
there are different actors
with different roles, right?
And basically, the movies are created
as a result of the interaction
of these different actors.
And each actors play
their different roles.
And it is very similar,
actually ourselves, our organs are formed
from a small functional
units called cells,
and have different cell types,
they have different functions.
And by interacting with each other,
they form our body,
and they form our organs.
And stem cells,
they are like an actor
who can play any role.
So the stem cells,
it's the kind of actor who
already have the script,
who's already familiar with this role.
And they can just go in the movie
and play the parts
when they get the signal.
So stem cells are type of cells,
they can transform into,
we say differentiated
into different cell types.
And my laboratory,
we are working on stem
cells found in the skin.
So today I want to
introduce to you the skin
and talk more about the
stem cells in the skin.
So I'm gonna share my
screen to show some slides
with the cartoons of skin.
I think you need to enable me to...
Thank you.
Okay, so this is how our skin looks like.
This is always like cartoon.
Hopefully today, we will
also see with our own eyes
how it looks like.
But it has different compartments.
So can you also see the mouse?
- [Lizzie] Yes.
- Okay cool.
So this upper compartment
is called epidermis.
So this is basically what see
when we look at our arms.
This is the outer part of our skin,
and it is called epidermis.
And under the epidermis,
there is this part which is called dermis.
And dermis has its own cell types,
and also there are blood
vessels, and also neurons.
And the other compartment
that we can actually see
with our eyes is the hair follicles.
And similar to epidermis and dermis,
hair follicles are also made
from different types of cells.
So this is the big picture
of how our skin looks like.
Now we're gonna zoom in
to the epidermis part.
So here, as you can see,
our epidermis actually,
when we look from outside,
it doesn't seem very complex,
but actually, it's a very complex tissue.
It forms from different layers.
Here in the basal layer,
we actually have our stem cells.
And in the other layers,
we have different type of cells.
And as I mentioned earlier,
this stem cells in the basal layer,
they can differentiate
into the other cell types.
So I want to ask you again
in a very fun poll question.
There is no right or wrong answer,
just to interact with each other.
Do you know why the stem
cells might be important?
Or why do you think we're
working on stem cells,
we are trying to understand their biology?
I'm just going to wait a little bit more.
So most of you said both,
and that is correct.
So yes, stem cells,
since they have this property
of making a different cell types,
they can actually regenerate a tissue.
And also, they play role in
certain skin disease as well.
So here now, I think though,
I will start with wound healing
because I think this is
one of the great examples
of how some cells regenerate a tissue.
So I think probably a lot of
you can relate with the wounds.
And as you all know that
when you have wounds,
it actually heals pretty quickly,
and that's kind of awesome.
And what happens is
actually when we have wounds
or we have an open area
in our skin, right?
And we haven't talked about it,
but the main role of our skin is
it is actually our protective organ.
It protects us from infections
or invasion of the microbes
outside our body, right?
And when we have this open wounds,
actually, we are exposed
to those infections.
So when there is this wounding,
actually our stem cells,
they sense this,
and they become activated.
So first, they actually start
to make more stem cells.
And then, they migrate through,
move through this wounded area.
And then they start making
different cell types.
So in this case, I said, for example,
stem cells are like an
actor who can play any role.
And when they are getting signal,
they play a part in the movie.
Like in this case, for example,
this signals is these wounds.
When there is wound,
now they're like, "Okay, I am needed."
And now, they start to
make different cell types.
And there are actually chronic ones.
And some people have a chronic ones.
These are type of wounds, it doesn't heal.
So they actually need to get treatments.
And there is, for example, other cases,
for example, if we have a small burn,
that's easy to heal,
but we can also have the big burns,
like first degree burns.
And those are much difficult to recover.
So now, if we understand
how the stem cells work,
if we understand their biology,
we can actually find treatment
for chronic wounds or this kind
of large burns, skin burns.
And this is actually something
called stem cell therapy.
And the other thing as you
already know is stem cells
play role in diseases as well.
There are many different
type of skin diseases.
And one of them is for
example, skin cancers.
And my lab is actually
working on both wound healing
and also skin cancers.
So basically what cancer
is when there's stem cells,
they go out of control.
So actually, some people refer for example
skin cancer as non-healing wounds.
And the reason is that in wounds,
stem cells start to make more stem cells
and other cells pods
because they are needed, right?
But in the case of cancer,
even if they are not needed in that area,
they start to proliferate
which means they make more stem cells
and then they form this tumors.
And in some cases,
the stem cells actually gained,
not just stem cell,
this transform cancer cells,
they gain the ability to escape from skin.
And as I showed in the initial slides,
under the skin,
there is dermis and
there are blood vessels.
And if they extend from the epidermis,
they can actually go into a blood vessel,
and this cancer cells can spread
to other organs and form tumors
in other organs as well.
And how this...
Sorry.
And how these cells are cancerous
as stem cells go out of control,
and they transform into tumor cells.
It's still under investigation.
As scientists, we're
still trying to understand
how this is happening.
So one thing is, for example,
UV lights can cause this transformation
if they expose our skin to UV light
for a very long time,
which is the sun is
emitting UV light as well
even if we can't see them.
Then it may cause the
transformation of the cells
to cancerous cells,
the normal cells to cancer cells.
And that's kind of why we need
to wear sunscreen creams
to protect our body.
So do you have any questions so far?
You can stop me whenever.
Okay.
So,
then how are we gonna...
So it's clear.
It is important to
understand the stem cells,
their biology,
how they differentiate
into different stem cells
so that we can find treatments for wounds,
for burns, or for skin diseases, right?
And then you need tools
to study stem cells.
And I think one thing that will be cool is
if we were able to see them.
When I look at my skin,
I don't see any cell stuff, right?
But there is a tool called microscope,
which basically magnifies the objects.
And so with microscopes,
we are actually able to
see much smaller objects
that we can't see with our eyes.
And here, I actually want to, again,
ask you a small question.
Do you know what we can see
with the light microscopes?
What is the smallest thing we can see
with a light microscope?
(indistinct chatter)
- [Teacher] What can you see?
Which organelles can you see?
- [Student] Mitochondria.
- [Teacher] Good, mitochondria. What else?
- [Teacher] Excellent. Good.
What other organelles?
- [Student] Cell membrane.
- [Teacher] Cell membrane, you can see.
(faintly speaking)
- [Teacher] Excellent!
Good job, Rosie!
Good for you.
(faintly speaking)
- [Irem] You already
know so much about them.
It's so cool.
So yeah, most of you say cell organelles.
This is correct.
They can see organelles
with the microscope.
And actually, there are different types
of microscope for different purposes.
And we are even able to see
proteins with the microscope.
With powerful microscope,
we can actually see proteins as well.
But today with our light microscope,
we will look for the stem cells.
So actually, I was watching YouTube videos
of previous rockEDU events,
and I find this very cool link
that I want to share with you
to kind of understand the scale
of the microscope and how
much we magnify the objects.
So, okay.
So, okay, We'll start
with the coffee bean.
We can see the coffee bean
with our eyes as well.
And we can start to magnify it even more
with the microscope.
Now with higher magnification,
we can even see now grain of salt.
And our microscopes is very powerful.
They can even magnify
unicellular organisms
such as amoeba.
And today, we will actually
look for skin cells.
So as you can see,
skin cells is only 30 micrometers in size.
And coffee bean, it is
in millimeter range.
So we will be really,
really, really magnifying
very tiny cells and looking
under microscope today.
With that, I think we can
go to our microscope room.
I'm just gonna mute myself
while I'm going there.
And I need to carry my laptop.
And meanwhile, if you have any question,
please feel free to write the chats.
Okay. I'm back, sorry.
So, okay, I will show
you the microscope room.
So our room is dark
because here we have light microscopes.
and that's why basically,
they are working with emitting
lights on the samples.
Therefore, we don't want any extra light.
That's why it is dark.
With my phone,
I will try to show you the room.
Okay.
So this is our microscope room.
We have different type of microscopes.
So this is the simplest one.
This is we only use to dissect the skin,
like separate the skin tissue.
This doesn't have very
high magnification power.
And today, I'm gonna
show you this microscope.
And this is a light microscope
called fluorescent microscope.
And first, maybe I can start
with showing you the parts
of this microscope.
So this part is called stage.
This is where we place our sample.
And this is eye piece.
This is where we look our samples.
And here, as you can see,
we have these lenses.
So this is called objective.
And these are basically
what magnifies our sample
or our specimen.
So, okay.
You can see.
No.
Can I move this?
Okay.
So here, as you can see,
there are actually different
type of objectives.
So each this objectives has a
different magnification power.
So for example,
now, this is turning into the 10x1.
So I will start showing you with the 10x1,
and then we will move
to higher magnification
to see the power of the
increasing the magnification
of the lenses.
Oops!
Okay now, I will grab my...
Oh, I dropped my...
Sorry.
Okay, so I will start with
showing you our skin samples.
Maybe, I will switch into my laptop again.
Okay.
Yes.
Now I will show you...
Sorry.
Some of our skin samples,
and how they look basically.
This is a slide.
Maybe I can turn this.
It's working better.
Okay.
So this is slide.
We basically put our
samples on this slide.
And you can put whatever you want,
like you can put any
samples that you want.
You can put blood droplets,
you can put plants.
In our case, our specimen,
our sample is skin tissue.
So I think it is difficult
to see with camera.
But here, you can still see these lines.
This is actually where our skin
is right now on this slide.
This is actually a technique
that we use in lab called sectioning.
These are skin sections.
So what is sectioning is,
let's think an apple.
Apple has a three
dimensional volume, right?
It has a length,
it has depth,
and it has a breadth.
And you can image an apple
as it is in a more
three dimensional space.
And the other way what you can do is
you can make a very thin slices of apple.
And this is basically saying
you can image the whole tissue
as more in a three dimensional form
or you can make a very thin slice,
so it's what we call a section,
an image more in a two dimensional form.
And today, we will look
more two dimensional images.
But then at the end,
I will try to show you also the difference
between how it is look when
you image the whole tissue
versus the sections.
So again, this where our samples are now.
And I'm gonna put this to
the stage to image them.
Okay, so this is our microscope.
Okay, I'm gonna to put my slide here.
And the light, it will
emit from this objective
on my sample,
And this is basically how these lenses
magnifies those samples.
Okay.
And basically using this thing,
it's like a joystick.
I don't know.
Can you see it?
Yes.
Joystick, we can move our slides.
Okay, and our microscope,
it is actually connected to,
it is connected to computer.
So we can see our images
on screen like this.
Okay, let's start.
I will again switch to my phone.
Okay, so if you can see
the room right now, right?
It's my phone, it looks good.
Great.
Okay, so now let's start
with looking our skin sample
by moving this stage.
I will find my tissue.
And here, we can actually get live images.
We need to make this bright field first.
So first, we will use a bright field,
which is basically a normal
light, illuminating our sample.
Okay.
So I will actually use the
eyepiece first
because it will make it better.
So these are the eyepiece.
And I can also see the
samples through eyepiece.
- [Lizzie] So Irem, would you be able
to explain a little bit of
what's happening right now?
- [Irem] Oh yeah, sorry.
So right now, I'm trying to
find my samples on this slide.
So my sample is located
in a certain place.
So by using the eyepieces,
I'm gonna find my sample.
And this is the basic of the light,
how the light pass,
it shows the path of the light.
Here, for example, it passed
through the objective.
And here, I can change to versus eyepiece,
this is the place we look the samples
or it's through the camera.
So I can switch this to camera.
And then here I can choose,
when I see live,
I will this be side seeing
on the screen our tissue.
So this is 10x.
So this is our skin.
We can already see it little bit better.
But as you can see,
we can't really say which part is what.
I can't say this is actually epidermis.
And I know this part,
like this part is dermis,
but this is actually very
difficult to understand.
And we can go higher magnification.
So let's do that.
And here actually, I need...
So this is actually something
help us to focus the image.
So when I move it, as you can see,
image become more clear.
So this is basically something
we use to move the stage.
Okay.
As you can see,
when I choose to higher
magnification objectives
such as 20,
This is 20.
Now, our tissue gets bigger.
And I can see much better that's like,
this is here, there's like epidermis,
and this part is dermis.
And I think here, there is
actually growing hair follicle.
But as you can see from the image,
it's not very clear.
If you can't really detect the details.
And it says we can't
actually see the cells.
So actually what we do to
be able to detect the cells
is using this technique called
immunofluorescent staining.
So to that now, I'm gonna
again switch to my laptop,
and show you some slides
to explain how immunofluorescent
staining works.
So our cells actually have
these molecules called proteins.
And proteins has different
size, different shape,
and a different function.
For example, there are some proteins
that provide a more structural support,
for example, gives cells their shape.
And there are other proteins
more have for example,
the chemical reactions to occur.
And some proteins that are
found in every cell types
of the skin are mainly
different cell types.
And there are some proteins,
it says very specific
to certain cell types.
For example, protein A can be
specific to only stem cells,
but not the other different
cell types of the skin.
Then what we can do is we can
actually use those proteins
to detect those cells.
So what we do is actually,
the three cells with a
molecule called antibody.
And these antibodies, they're
actually called nice proteins.
So this antibody specific for protein A,
we can also have another
antibody specific for protein B.
And these antibodies that
are attached to fluoro form,
this is basically, you don't really need
to remember any of these names,
but this is basically molecule
that when you eliminates that light,
this fluoro form ignites light itself.
And it has different fluoro forms,
it has different colors.
Here for example, it can be green
or it can be red, it can be blue.
By using different colored fluoro forms,
we can detect different proteins.
So we can detect different
compartments of tissue
and different cell types.
And now actually, in order
to see our skin compartments,
we gonna look for some
immunofluorescence stain samples.
Okay.
And now, I am taking my strain sample.
So this is again,
I'm again using the slides.
And now, I'm going to
turn this light off too,
because now we will start emitting
different color of lights on our sample.
Okay.
- [Lizzie] So is this the same sample
that we saw before just
with different colors
associated with it?
- Again, this similar skin tissue,
but this time we treat them
with these molecules with the fluoro form
with colorful text,
so that we can see the different
types of our skin tissue.
Okay.
So let me switch back to my phone.
Okay, now again, I will
put my slide on the stage.
So the first thing I would like to do,
again, by using this joystick,
I will try to find my sample on my slides.
And here, this time, I will choose a color
because now my sample is colored
with the treatment off those antibodies.
Okay, so let's see.
Also, I actually need to turn,
I'm gonna turn off the
light in the room too,
but I think it's really fine.
Okay, so now, I found my sample.
Now, I need to focus my
sample again using this thing.
This is basically moving
our objective up and down.
Okay.
So here, this is...
Oops!
So now we can already see in more details,
although I am not sure
if you see very clearly.
So yeah, this is the staining
that stains for the nucleus of the cell,
which is basically the
control center of the cells,
It's an organelle.
And here, we can see hair follicles.
These are going through the dermis.
And now, we're gonna
look for different colors
to detect different parts of our tissue.
Okay, so.
So this green color,
actually the type of
protein called keratin 14.
I think probably, you guys already heard
about the keratin.
because like on shampoos,
like there are things like
keratin treatment for the hair.
So basically, keratin is a
protein found in the cells.
It's actually support the
structure of the cells.
And actually our stem cells,
they have different
types of keratin compared
to other cell types.
So this is a keratin 14.
And now, we are actually
using those antibodies
that detecting keratin 14.
We can actually see our stem cells.
As I showed in the cartoon,
they are found in the basal
layer of our skin tissue.
And also our hair follicles,
they also have the same keratin protein,
so we can also see our
hair follicles as well.
So this is more an adult skin.
As you can see it has a
very big hair follicle
that goes deep into the dermis.
And we'll try to focus a little bit more.
Now, I'm gonna also show you
a little bit earlier stage
of the skin,
and we will again continue
looking for different parts.
Oh, I also realized, it's already 4:00.
So okay let me show you
some more screening,
so that we also have time
to chat a little bit more.
Okay.
Here I'm also again
trying to find my tissue.
Okay.
So I find my tissue.
Again, I'm trying to focus.
Okay here, you can see,
this is a more early stage of skin.
So we have tiny hair follicles.
They are not growing as much.
Here again, you see the stem
cells in the basal layer.
And now, we will gonna look
for the other cell types.
Here, it is more different cell types
with the different color.
And now, I can take an image
and then actually see this
layered state of the skin,
the layered structure of the skin.
And let me take a snap.
Now our microscope is taking the image.
Okay, so if I zoom in here,
so as you can see now,
we can detect with this technique.
The stem cells in the basal part,
and then the differentiated cells
in the more an upper layer
using those different colors.
And here, this part is not stained
because this is the dermis.
And these colors that I am using,
they are specific for the epidermal cells.
So I can very nicely
see the epidermis parts.
It starts from here to here,
goes through here.
And I can actually show you
more images on my slides,
which will be I guess, more clear to see.
So if I share my screen again.
For example, this is an image I take.
So the right part is more
three dimensional as I said,
and the left part is
basically what we did today.
It's more in sections.
It's more 2D.
Here for example again,
what we look is the stem cells in green.
And here actually, I
stained for blood vessels
of the dermis.
So in 3D, you can see like
the hair follicles grow
through the dermis,
their interaction with
these blood vessels.
And the 3D image is also very powerful
because then you can
have a more clear idea
how the structure looks like.